oh my god
scary movie 5 5
yes 42 about the life of Jackie Robinson
also comes out this weekend sorry Jackie
Robinson I'll review the movie about
your amazing and inspiring life tomorrow
in the meantime let's talk about a movie
with some real class so scary movie 5 is
it's scary movie 5 which is funny
because I thought that came out I
thought scary movie 5 was a haunted
house sounds like okay that's scary
movie 5 I don't want to see it I don't
need to see it I don't want to talk
about it but the universe was like okay
guys Jeremy didn't get the message he's
supposed to do a video on this and waste
his time so let's do that again and then
call it scary movie 5 and it's probably
gonna keep happening until I do a video
about it and sometimes it's just fun to
talk about something that's terrible
it's so scary movie 5 stars Ashley
Tisdale yeah you heard that right that's
what it is that's how it goes down
they spoof mama and paranormal activity
forward they don't just spoof horror
movies they spoof other movies like Rise
of the Planet of the Apes and inception
the inception segment actually did make
me laugh but it's not because it was
good because dude they got to
impersonate DiCaprio actually made me
laugh I was like it's yeah he looks and
sounds like DiCaprio from inception like
a caricatured version of DiCaprio from
Inception that's just my personal funny
bone thing right there some of the
stupidest acts I've ever seen on MADtv I
went yeah because someone was an
exaggerated version of a celebrity and
that just made me laugh at the very
beginning of this movie Charlie Sheen's
banging Lindsay Lohan they play
themselves and they get kills boiler
alert they get killed in the beginning
you're welcome then text comes up and
it's like Charlie Sheen's body was found
on October 27th his body didn't stop
partying for two days or something like
that yeah the funniest part of the movie
is in text form example they're spoofing
Mama's little kids like don't look in
the closet Ashley Tisdale opens the
closet door and the maids in there
taking a [ __ ] on the toilet and then she
shits and flies off the toilet and hits
Ashley Tisdale and I was like why is
there a toilet in the closet in the kids
bedroom they put it there so they can
have that moment that's not funny
if the house structure of a house
doesn't make sense in a spoof type
comedy because they change it up to
accommodate and put in a scene that's
actually there for a laugh that actually
gets a laugh then it makes
just didn't they do spoof evil dead in
this movie a movie that came out one
week ago which I actually believe I
believe they started production of scary
movie 5 last weekend alright yeah so
they already knew what Evil Dead was
going to be about and I knew the plot
points they can spoof in the movie and
make it like the new Evil Dead before
the movie came out I get that it's
almost embarrassing because you know the
guy who directed this movie in the ones
who wrote this movie they're like oh
this is really good it's funny scary
movie 5 was written by a couple of old
dudes who were there had a touch at this
points like when your grandfather's like
oh what's this it's a quarter you're
like did you really pull a quarter out
of my ear grandpa I'm 28 but you kind of
go all right cool cuz he's family only
thing is scary movie 5 is not family you
don't have that internal obligation you
just look at it and go why am I here
scary movie 5 is [ __ ] so that's what
I did with my day I watched this because
I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] where's your
favorite spoof comedy what's your
favorite spoof comedy out there whatever
it is comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more